Mikhail Friedman built his fortune in
Vladimir Putin's Russia a deal between
his oil company and BP was endorsed by
the Russian president and Tony Blair
ukrainian-born and now based in London
he's been hit by European Union
sanctions but says he has no influence
on the man Waging War on his homeland
imposing sanction against us here just
create an enormous pressure for us
personally but we do not have any impact
for political decision you say you have
no links to Vladimir Putin but despite
the city of your birth being under
attack you've offered no condemnation
some might conclude you're more
concerned about your money than your
country what would you say to them I'm
also worrying about the country but I'm
first of all worrying about people who
are working for us
you know we have a lot of you know very
prominent people in the top management
the general image as I said it's
hundreds of thousands of people working
for us in in Russia and you know I I
don't want to to make any comment which
potentially could increase their risk
he controls a global business Empire
that runs from energy to retail from
these London offices benefiting he says
from the transparency and security the
City offers
Mikhail Friedman has not been sanctioned
by the UK but the government says it
does have a list of oligarchs against
whom it will take action as it tries to
put pressure on Vladimir Putin by making
life in London less comfortable and less
lucrative for his super rich allies
it's long been a magnet for foreign
wealth and dirty money says an author
being sued this week for his expose of
oligarchs this is where you can hire the
propaganda Specialists the PRS the
lawyers to defend your reputation
um and of course you can buy everything
from
um bits of universities to mansions and
private school places
also sanctioned by the EU but not
Britain Uzbek billionaire Alicia usmanov
seen here with Chelsea owner Roman
Abramovich
former shareholder in Arsenal and now
sponsor of Everton he says the
allegations against him are false and
will challenge the West's attempt to
change the rules of the game Paul Kelso
Sky News